okay yes so thank you for those of you
who made it I guess most people already
went home at the end of today so today
I'm gonna talk about testing Rothwell
and how you can do that in a way that
you're testing all the functions of your
Kafka well server or maybe your client
so today it won't be about explaining
what golf course or how you can use it
but most to be about testing so also if
you are in the experience for testing
like you can figure it out during the
slides so a lot of people actually don't
test their code so especially big
companies are doing this they've got all
the slow balancers they got like a
thousand servers or maybe working
surplice they usually don't really test
the code because as soon as something
breaks they will see it in the metrics
and users won't do it but if you've got
smaller applications or maybe you want
to have an idea about your code
stability then testing is a good idea
so when testing in production always
make sure that you have load balancers
or if not just implement testing so a
little bit about myself so my name is
Roy I mostly work on open source
projects for the city of Amsterdam where
every building sort of a data hub for
all the open data that we have in the
city and we open source at using Python
api's also a little bit of Kafka well
and mostly react on the front end I also
teach graphic well at reacts Kafka
Academy and I work with other companies
as an adviser so why write test so there
are a lot of reasons to actually write
tests some are like big reasons some are
smaller reasons so I highlighted some of
the reads instead I used myself that I
used myself when I tried to get people
to testing so one of these is check if
code behaves as expected so you're
writing a function you want to know if
it's function actually works the way you
expect it if maybe an entire code block
works as expected so let's for me the
main reason to actually test my code see
if it works as I expected and in the end
it will save you a lot of trouble and
it's trouble you will get saved when
you're testing for errors and edge cases
so usually you make exceptions in your
code and there are stuff in there that's
only you know are only your team knows
about so if you have to hand over this
project and it's really hard to actually
see why these exceptions are there and
if you put testing applies for his
exceptions it's really easy to
understand them and why they're there
and they're probably a lot of more
reasons on a high over level that are
important when applying testing but for
me these are like the high over stuff I
use when talking to product managers
that actually have to pay for all the
time that goes into testing so a bit
more practical reasons is it makes
refactoring easier because a lot of time
we do refract ring you're changing a lot
of your code and then in the end maybe
your functionality is broken or maybe
you've broken some of the functionality
that you didn't know was there so if the
worst test case for edge cases then you
probably would have found it but
otherwise it makes refactoring easier
because if you assume this simple
function so you actually take an average
of two variables and you're dividing
them by 2 to find out the value so your
test case you're just checking if the
average of two and two is four it's one
sorry now to the end of the day so if
you were to affected this function and
instead of dividing him you would do it
times 0.5 it left the same result and so
a test won't break so you can refractor
all this code and it's just a simple
function suppose it was a really big
function and the output should be the
same if you would have testing in place
you can still see if your code works as
expected and this is just for like a
simple pure function if you could bigger
functions or more complicated educators
I don't have any testing in there you
probably will break functionality
without even knowing it so another thing
is improving your code quality so as you
saw before like this is an easy test it
already improves the code quality
because you can refactor without
breaking stuff and also a lot of time
with our big debugging things because
you don't know where things went wrong
and something I experienced when testing
a lot like difficult complex codes
that's complexity rated it's really hard
to test because tests are meant to be
simple and easy and your functions
actually should be as well so it's
better to break up functions and smaller
functions in my opinion it proves the
code quality and it also makes testing
easier and debugging so that's why
testing is also important and the last
one is something I really like when I
start on new projects so every time you
start a new project you need to get a
look of you need to get familiar with
the code base and if there isn't any
documentation or the documentation is
outdated then it can be really hard to
get familiar with a code base so if you
have a lot of testing in place and
you've written stuff things
things down like this then it becomes
way easier because he can immediately
see all the hidden futures in the code
so actually you can use the test cases
and all the test scenarios as a
documentation for your code so you get
an in-depth knowledge about what should
be doing and especially if you apply
stuff like test-driven development then
you probably have set up all your other
user stories like this and you story
should be stick test scenarios and then
becomes way easier to actually get
familiar with new code bases so if you
want to apply these things to graphic
well basically is it's all like high
over you can apply all these apparence
to graph coil but let's first look at
what we can actually test for a graph
coil server appliance so we can test
schemas right so if you ski mass and
your schemas of certain types and these
are things that should be really easy to
test or queries will they have to exact
same outcomes you've expected these old
things you can test by testing the
schemas and you can do the same thing
for resolvers resolvers are actually
things that are getting the data for you
you probably want to test doubts because
you want to know if either your database
connection is set up straight there or
maybe some logic you imply there is
working as be expected
and probably you can also test more
thing some server-side because we could
ski mask because resolvers we also got
the actual server that is running and
something that you could do with some
packages actually load testing on a
graphic well server it is quite
interesting something we will look at
the very end if we still some time so
you would actually want to test the
server as well so not only the schemas
and resolvers but also how your server
behaves and even how it behaves if you
put a lot of queries a lot of if you
send a lot of queries to them because
maybe your queries are too complex maybe
your setup but the database is too
complex you want to know that the same
we should test SQL queries in order
types of servers or you can also test it
client-side and it's something we will
see later on with the demo as well and
are multiple ways to actually test it so
as you can see you can do static type
checking so I would really I would
really prefer to use some sort of
language that has static type checking
so either it's with typescript or
JavaScript with some extensions or maybe
you working with more functional
languages if you got static types in
there
and the amount of errors between you
actually schemas and your resolvers and
how do we actually be output it'll be
way smaller because you're already
checking the types multiple times not
only in your schemas
but also throughout your resolvers so
that's something that's really useful
and unit tests ugh
also we have a lot of unit tests in
place so you can unit test maybe your
schemas you resolve a scan of units
tests and integration tests so you want
to know how your resolvers and schemas
work together or maybe how you resolve
this work together which database that
stuff you would test in integration
tests and we might also have end-to-end
tests so maybe you want to test the
entire lifecycle so from your ski mask
to your resolvers to your queries and
actually how it would end up in your
clients so nth winter so most have been
part in the client side and then we can
lay it around make it a version between
mocking stuff and actually testing
against your life or your test databases
so there are multiple strategies you can
apply when testing code so a lot of a
pattern are used to be really popular
was this one select the testing pyramid
you would have unit tests at the bottom
and you have integration tests in the
middle and you probably have end-to-end
tests on top and the reason behind this
was because unit tests are relatively
easy to make that cost you less effort
effort because they're really testing
small units of code block of code they
can run quite fast integration tests are
a bit slower because you're already
testing multiple layers of code maybe
you're testing the integration with
schemas and resolvers or maybe resolves
through the database so this slows a
little bit up an end-to-end tests are
especially slow because they involve
like multiple products maybe so maybe
they involve your client the info few
server they can full for database so
throughout your entire code stick it
will involve basically everything so
that's why they run really slow and
usually they are harder to make the
dissipater not used to be really popular
if you ask a lot of project managers is
more like this because they don't really
care about unit tests they only want to
see the actual outcome of your tests so
they want to see maybe with something
like Cypress how actually users are
going through your code is your login
flow still working can people still pay
so a lot of product managers actually
prefer this one because it's really
visible for them what's actually
happening well at a developer you want
to see if your code is working and then
probably
it becomes easier to debug things of
functionality later on so another
pattern it's become really popular is
the trophy one that's right here so what
you would have here at the button you
would have static charge at static type
check and so that's actually where you
would start
so by using something like typescript or
maybe a functional programming language
they would have setec type checking so
that's the first portion and then you
would have some unit test because if you
apply static type chapping it's less
it's less common to have a lot of unit
tests because you're already testing a
lot of things that you would test in
unit test so we'll my string be a string
that stuff you already have covered
while you're checking your types and
then in the middle you would have
integration tests because there are a
lot more interesting because they
actually involve multiple multiple
products in your life cycle so that's
why they are interesting and then to top
you have end-to-end tests so you can see
the division between integration test
unit test static typing they're all like
less obvious so this is a pattern I
prefer actually so first let's start at
how we can actually test the schemas so
for this on the left you can see basic
implementation of something some part of
my schema that constructed so this is a
type 4 product you can see it's called
type product it's got two fields you've
got a title their price and to test this
you can look on the right side so to do
there we're importing the types and I'm
actually really easy going to check if
your type is your type as you expect it
to be so this test isn't that you don't
really get a lot of wins by this test
but it's good for your test coverage of
the test coverage doesn't really say
anything but if you got more complex
types maybe could ferry runs or
fragments in there then comes more
interesting test stuff like this so
schema testing can actually be quite
easy so if you got more or bigger
schemas or maybe you've got remote
schema stitching in place you would have
different different types of tests so a
lot of packages you can use for this
fellow good packages for this and
something I really like is easy graphic
well so you could install it from NPM
and you convert it on every JavaScript
implementation of graphic well and stuff
you can do whatever smokings you
amok results of queries and tests
against them or you can actually test
assertions right away so here's like a
basic implementation of how to actually
get your schema so with this but it's
like lines of code you can actually
import your schema maybe from a local
directory maybe from an external
directory to actually have your schemas
in there so you can mock smoke against
them and then a mock would look like
this so you've got your query on the
right side you implement some variables
and you mock it later on so first it's
the query run to test so we want to get
the product and we've got one variable
which is the product ID and we want to
return some fields and also some
subfields and then you can define you
actually want to mock errors as well so
maybe you want to handle how your graph
queries will handle errors or maybe
while you serve for behind it you would
do it like this you would just define
you want to mock errors as well so you
can test your error messages and in the
end you can make a searchings against
these mock so basically you're just
smoking educating the results and then
it will be a JSON object you can
actually see if the jason objectives as
expected just you can see on the right
side we've got three views and
apparently reviews is supposed to be an
array so everywhere in your code you're
gonna assume reviews is an array so you
want to test those things in your
surgeons so that's how you can basically
implement schema testing as well and
something else you could do with easy
graphic world tester is making
assertions directly so you can actually
test if queries or mutations will
succeed so that's done like this so on
the right side you again you can see the
same query as we just saw and instead of
mocking them we're gonna directly use
the to test the searching to see whether
or not it's valid so you can send in
product IDs you can do the same for
mutations and in here it saves you a lot
of code but you could less knowledge
about what actually will be the result
of this so it really depends on how I
want to do this do you want the basic
testing for your ski masks you can do it
like this it's really easy it's like
making snapshots you're done really
quick if we're not have more knowledge
about what actually is returned by your
queries you would mock them and just see
the results from there
so that's something you can find on the
website from easy graphic well as well
there's a really nice demo that links to
Sandburg coats and books and in there
you can find all those smoking and a
search in things as well and they go
really far they've got queries with
variants so it's really interesting if
you're working with bigger ski masks to
actually test them with easy groove coil
tester so resolvers that's another thing
we can test so as we saw before we can
test ski masks we can test resolvers and
we can test more things surface ID right
so we can look at this overs now and
something that's really important to
know is resolvers are pure functions if
somewhere in your code base you have
side effects
really near resolvers you should get
them out because resolver should be pure
functions that's how they actually were
meant to so we did in mind it's you can
figure out how easy it will be to test
them so suppose pure functions like a
black box right you put something in and
based on that outputs something will
come out and even though every time I
put in a certain thing like maybe every
time I put in maybe some beer and
friends you can expect the same outcome
unless there are side effects so maybe
there's a pregnant girlfriend for some
of your friends that is getting into
problems they would have side effects
but assuming you don't have any side
effects you probably would have a good
time when you put these things in there
so that's why resolver should be pure
functions and if you want to test them
and they have side effects it's good
really are because you need to define
all those side effects need to find
Emma's edge cases how are you gonna
handle them so that's why you really
should try and make them pure functions
and if they are they should be really
easy to test rights because you will
know every time I put something in in
this shape something in that shape will
come out if I put something in with
these fields like that fields will come
out it's something you should really
have any resolvers because your
resolvers are very actually collect the
information for your schemas so if there
are side effects in there then it
becomes really hard to test them later
around when you actually test your
queries so in practice if you want to
test resolvers that's something you
could do with packages as well but you
don't really need Becca Jesus they are
just your script functions or maybe
Python or whatever language you've
written your graphic well server in so
assume this resolver so it's really a
simple resolver it's thinking an object
it just probably do have to parent
object for product it says some context
so maybe it'll get something out of the
database there and it also takes
arguments so leave anything everything
besides you will always know if you put
an object in with like a review object
in there then it will return something
based on that review object and if there
aren't any side effects you can probably
really easy test if you put something in
that exact same app which is you expect
it will come out so you would test it
something like this it would just import
your resolver people said maybe an
object that you want to have input and
then you can just see if it still it's
the same result as you expect it so if
you keep these Aspira function it's
really easy to test them and also maybe
if you do some alterations to your
reviews object then still those
alterations should be testable so maybe
you should be strange if you maybe
change like field types or something
else and if you do then it should be
described somewhere so you can actually
test it and so for integration test we
can do a lot of stuff as well
so usually integration tests that are
most interesting for graphic well
servers are ones where you would
actually mock your schema or may or
maybe mom to juice the entire server and
test your resolvers you actually want to
see if your queries function as expected
so for this you can actually mock
servers which can be quite easy if you
maybe set up your cough call server
Tupelo or maybe if you don't know
something else it should be it should be
that our two credits MOCA information
maybe you can create an entire mock
server as well directly in postmen or
something else so we can see with
integration tests the mocking api's it's
usually something like this right so you
mocked your api with actually there's
nothing gods there's no database so you
don't have to worry about database
connections when you're testing you're
doing integration testing cough quell
server because you don't actually need
the internet connection and you can just
run in your CI so I've made a small
example with the pulao for this and
we're Apollo it's really easy when you
create your cough quell server to
actually implement mocking as well so
it's basically dish done like this so
you define your resolvers you define
your schemas with your type devs
and then you create your Apollo server
and you put in one extra field and that
smokes is true and when you insert this
your entire schema will be mocked and
also if you want have more advanced use
cases you can also have your resolvers
mocked so maybe you want to resolvers to
mutate your data in some way then you
would define like custom mock resolvers
to get the data there and you can
actually use it together with postman as
well because the newest postman releases
they've got the option to send in graph
QL query as a body request as a body of
type so as you can see it's only in a
better fields which you can actually
there's a small trick for it if you're
using all the postman's postman versions
you can just change the content type to
applications let's graph quell and then
it should work as well let's try this
so yeah let's look at this first so I've
got a server to find here let's refresh
it just to be sure yes this one's still
running I've got a server defined here
and we want to mock this right so we can
just add this one here should be
interesting to see how the mocking will
work so can just do it like this
yeah maybe we can test a little small
query here so this is actually products
query Richard just saw so we're getting
ID title thumbnail some other fields and
now this is actually Daddy you want to
receive right so you're looking for
products you get stuff like a blue
t-shirts that's probably correct so if
you implement mocking for this
first here as well
as MOOCs sorry okay so if we add the
MOOCs to there you can see we could like
hello world we've got strange digits so
now you know your data is mocked so this
is actually mocking based on your schema
so you can X you can also mark basing
resolver so maybe for more complex
situations you want to test but for now
just mucker our schema as you can see if
we good stuff like hello world the
digits will change all the time because
every time you send this query it will
be mocked so you got like first data to
test with so this is all done on this
server and you can find the type
definitions here so these are all stuff
we can test you in a request so if we
would go to postman so we've got this is
actually codes and books I'm using to
test this one yes so as you can see I'm
not sending any params but I'm sending a
body so in my body I can use this future
your future from postman to actually
test my queries in here and something I
can do is like actually sending this one
and look at the results so this is old
one with the blue t-shirts and then we
could send the new one and to actually
get the same mock data as we saw in the
graphical playground so with the smoke
data we can actually send up this
scenario is in postman because you can
test over there as well and if you're
working on larger API is that you also
want to share with other team members or
maybe companies that are working with
your API is the postman is really
convenient because you make Khmer
collections you can make MOOC servers
you can also monitor stuff so if you
have other people using your API so you
can monitor it all from there so if you
would want to test your graph coil
servers in here you can just create some
test scenarios for them so I already
created some so what I already created
was seeing if my response time is less
than two milliseconds so this one it's a
bit you don't really know if the actual
response time to serve will be that when
you mock it locally but maybe if you've
got a server in place you can test this
year and then we can see if products is
an array so when my products data is
being sent is being received like here
you can see it's an array so these all
things
testa maybe you can see reviewers is an
object you can go even further bruh
maybe testing of the reviews countess
like like a float or a number so we
could do it like this or maybe we can
just see if like the products title is a
string it's easier so you could just go
and look here maybe you would have title
and I can see if added like a test case
and this one works as well you can
immediately see if somehow someone
change to your API we didn't never know
if there is any versioning of place or a
lot of people working on your API if
somehow it is string ends up to be like
maybe an array or an object or an
integer you would know if you monitor if
you monitor your API is in here so this
is really convenient to work with like
before when I worked with REST API is a
lot I use postman on a daily basis then
came graph quail and mostly used to
playgrounds but now with this new future
I actually started using postman a lot
again and it's got a lot of functions
that you don't have in a regular graph
twelve playgrounds which is quite basic
yeah so if you would want to have this
test this code for the server as well
you can get at the error you will get
the redirected to the coats and book so
you can find like all the sample code to
set up the server and you can create
your own testing or maybe you could use
it as a back-end for something else okay
so we can also test on the client side
and testing on the client side can maybe
be a bit more interesting because there
it's actually very user is using the app
using graph guell server so maybe you
run into new problems maybe there was
something you didn't over see when you
create IP and you create the server so
let's look at client side testing so
again I used Java Script to create this
one and I'm making something weird to
react to pull out so what I've done here
I want to test this component so if you
aren't familiar with reactor polo let's
go so it gives you some components that
can handle your data flow if we can look
at this query component if you input a
graph query in there it'll automatically
parse it for you I will do the fetch
request and we will turn things like
like loading error and data but you want
the test of this actually work right
because you're using an external
component that you didn't write yourself
so it could be interesting to test these
components and as you can see this
component should in the end fill my divs
and my H elements with data from that
graph QL API API so we'd actually want
to see if titles displayed or not and
whether or not your graph growth server
returns this field so every three turns
this field is something you could
already have test it on your Mac inside
or with postman if you want to monitor
tutor
externally perdu it from the client side
you need to implement some other things
as well so there are multiple ways to do
this so one thing to do this is by
actually mocking the provider and
actually mocking the entire clients so
this is quite easy a false to do but
still it isn't that reliable but still
look at that we can do it as you can see
you're actually mocking the entire
result that comes back from your graph
güell server so this one it isn't really
reliable because still if you changed
MOOC data then maybe it will work your
test maybe doesn't work in your actual
application but suppose it does you can
see if we could a request and request as
a query and it's got a results any
results you'd have some data structure
that's similar to the one returned by a
server and you can just mock it and see
if your component works as expected so
this is sort of like a unit test for
your query components to see if this
component to actually function as you
would expect it once you give it mock
data as you can see we tested several
things so we actually gonna find or H
element and we're going to see whether
or not or text is rendered in there so
you can test it with this and your test
is in the mock so it should immediate
arts you're basically just testing the
function of the ji6 component and also
this is something i've got some code for
so if you were interesting this is using
the same server as you saw before if you
were doing them above you would actually
have a full stack graph quayle
application it uses JavaScript on the
backend with Apollo and JavaScript on
the fund and with react and also Apollo
so if you would look at this example so
first check if we still have a server
running because we would need that one
yeah so we still have a server running
and then we can go and look at this from
rad so I've basically set up a very
small application that's using a pillow
and react Apollo as well as you can see
I'm using the graph coil server I just
created also in code sandbox and I've
got a provider here where I attach the
client to and then I'm rendering the
products as you can see what this looks
like in the browser so this is nothing
fancy it's just like a list and some
input fields so if I would type
something in here first let's make sure
we turn off the mock here because real
data
yes I would real data now and we could
just add some fields to it an annex --an
fields to it as you can see it returns a
success message as well so these are
things you would might want to test and
also you want to see whether or not
there are more items in this list so
again yeah we set up this basic
application and its application has some
test in there as well so the first test
we can look maybe it's for the product
see with testing multiple things in here
so we're going to test if it renders
without error we're going to test if it
shows any loading indicator once the
server is loading and we're gonna see if
to actually run us the products I should
look at the product components it just
takes a query which we already saw
before which we have also tested in
postman and then we're gonna pass to the
query components and we might do some
stuff for there so we're loading we have
error and if there isn't any error we do
things with it like mapping it's showing
a title so these are things you can test
so you could use maybe snapshots like
code sandbox doesn't support snapshots
so that's why I left them out for you
but you could test for the snapshot just
look at lock you component looked like
but still it's the easy test but not
that reliable now you could see if it's
renders the loading states you can see
here we're testing whether or not the
loading States displayed so this should
be somewhere loading displayed in your
component 3 and then you can check if
the actually renders products and for
this we're using mock data so still it
isn't that reliable but it's something
to see if your UI works as expected
I can just see if you put those mocks in
there whether or not the titles display
it you can also do the same for error
messages so maybe you want to see
whether or not an error message
displayed whenever your server isn't
available these are just test for
products and perform to basically
they're quite the same so I want to see
whether or not it renders without an
error whether or not the loading
indicator is shown if you can edit over
so if the Edit message is shown whether
or not extra fields or edits these are
things you could test as well for your
forum which you can see in here so we
create I created some mocks for the refs
because reps are a bit tricky to the
mock so if you want to create controlled
components
don't use reps
because they're really hard to mock so
here we're just gonna see whether or not
your component loads we're gonna see if
the loading state is somewhere in there
and again we're using all mock data and
basically the same for adding offers I'm
rendering to access messages so if we
want to get this code you can just use
this QR code and find the goats and
books and play around with it and so
yeah flow through end-to-end testing you
would have for more complex one right
because you also want to test out your
server babes so if you were not to do
that you could just test using the real
Apollo provider so you're just testing
against real life data or maybe real
data from your test graph quayle server
that's using some test database so
basically all the implementation would
be the same except you can leave out the
mocks in a set of mocks using the actual
data so that's very more reliable
something else I would like to do there
are packages to help you do this is
actually importing your ski masks or
importing fields from your actual
database actual graph Guelph server and
use them as mocks so then you would
still have a reliable implementation so
as I said before you can also do load
testing so there's a small extra demo
I've included something to do load
testing with and basically what I've
implied it's another package from easy
graphic well so this is called ease of
quality and its load tester and with
this one you can load test your
applications you could send a certain
number of queries to it a certain number
of permutations you can at your own
variables and then you could choose how
many private users you want to test it
on so this is actually really convenient
if you want to find out how your actual
application would skill so you maybe you
built a graph coil server everything
works real nice
you've got queries that maybe have a
nesting depth of like six different
fields you could really interesting to
see how this would skill so it's stuff
like this you can actually test out with
skills so let's see looks like so
basically we're gonna test this graph
guell server
so well loads okay so basically what
you're doing here you can define certain
things you can see define whether or not
you want queries whether or not you want
citations the duration and arrival rate
whether or not you want to see the
outputs on your right side as well and
then you can define arguments so these
are the arguments for the query good
student by ID and this is from get
career so you can just define arguments
and yeah this is something good to
define for yourself do you want the same
argument so you want different arguments
these are all things you can implement
and then you can set input variables for
maybe mutations so let's see if we can
run this one so now you can see it sir
first it's gonna set up the application
so it's actually gonna mock a client
that will just send all these queries to
your server so this might take some time
yeah so we're just seeing right now is
just like getting no modules that you
would need to actually run a graph guell
client and now it's gonna send all these
requests so this is a lot of requests
being fired to graph guell server so
maybe if you've got unstable database
you'll find out after running a test
like this since you can see this one was
quite fast because it put the duration
of just one and as you can see there are
50 scenarios launched we've also got 50
completed so it's good nothing crashed
and also the were like thousand 50
requests being sent to your server so
you can probably imagine like within 10
seconds or so being thousand 50 requests
sent to your server I don't know if
you've ever looked at the github graph
guell API they actually limited the
amount of requests you consent and that
amount is way smaller than actual REST
API because with all the nesting and you
don't know how the people will go and
you've got a lot of relations then it's
really it can be quite tricky to
implement that well so if you don't have
any load testing for that you will
probably find out sooner or later that
your queries might be too big or maybe
you have to find too many relations that
are queryable so as you can see here
opens well you can also try running it
to baby like more or a different arrival
rate to see how this will actually
implement your your setup so that's a
package you can find right here and the
only thing you need to configure it is
just trying to run a batch script which
you can do locally and you would define
a config file and they would put in all
the variables and some configuration
amounts for like the number of requests
you want to send so if we would want to
wrap this all up like look at everything
we saw so for testing graph well there
are a lot of things we can do so we can
do static type checking so that's where
I step static type checking where I
would actually have typescript or
another functional programming language
using types so we didn't here you can
already get a lot of your you can
already do a lot of debugging because
maybe you will find out when you
actually have compiled everything that
they were errors in there so really to
get end-to-end type safety with gov
quell you would need some safety
checking and if you don't implement any
static type checking it's come really
interesting to actually have a lot of
unit test for your codes because you
want to know if the of your strings will
remain strings because otherwise they
will definitely break your code if your
tribal factor graph coil is all verse or
maybe you make changes to your schemas a
lot of things can break if you don't
define your types well and maybe if
you've got side effects in your
resolvers you're actually changing the
form of types that could be tricky as
well so that's why you would need unit
tests to make sure that these things are
in place and together with static type
checking they're sort of the basis for
your testing so if these things are in
place you've got probably sort of a
sable code base that can that can easily
be added new futures without breaking a
lot of things and then the integration
tests become a lot more tricky so as we
saw you could mock your server and then
try testing if it postmen or maybe you
can mock your server and test it in your
clients or maybe you can walk the
clients and test your actual server so
for integration tests there a lot of
options so whatever time options you
choose it really depends on what you're
building and how complex it is so maybe
your client is really important maybe
your gov quail server not so then we'd
implement more integration tests over
there and we can also do end-to-end
tests where I just test the entire
lifecycle so you would have your schemas
that are being tested by actually
querying a various versions of your
server and you would have to client the
next should be see how your data flows
to your client and actually if titles
will be rendered when you ask for when
you have a query where's a title in
there so then you can actually apply
end-to-end testing and really see if
your lifecycle from your graph quells
server to your client is working as
expected and then we also have load
testing so this one might be it's really
dependable on how many servers are using
maybe your running surface and then you
wouldn't really have to worry about this
just for a large bill for Amazon maybe
at the end of the month so with load
testing you can also it's not really
just testing if you need more servers
but also if you haven't written to
complex queries because see if you've
got maybe you're working with a sequel
database on the backend then you can
easily get like nest a lot of
relationships from people put in quite
serious queries so that stuff to think
about the new create your types as well
and then something that's important to
mention is like on a person test
coverage doesn't mean that you don't if
any bucks so books can arise everywhere
or maybe their side effects you haven't
tested maybe they were side effects you
have tested but actually something else
is going on but this coverage is like a
good metric if you've got some sort of
test coverage I don't know if you're
using javascript we just you can
generate these summaries of your code
you can actually see arm and most
important things test it or not so
something that Jess doesn't really see
is important so maybe whether or not a
label like sold outs or maybe if you
could have equal store so that's a lot
of things I work on our e-commerce
stores or marketplaces when you try to
render label next to product that either
says sold-out or hot item or maybe low
in shipments for Jesse's will be just a
branch with a small percentage
percentage so maybe I found a percent
and then there's this test that maybe if
eighty and this isn't tested so eighty
won't say anything so just to keep in
mind just look at those testimonies and
really see if you test the important
parts so then we're that for small
question like if you implement graph
guell which you really preferred like to
have a lot of unit test and static type
checking an integration test on top or
end-to-end which you really prefer to
have like more end-to-end testing and
integration test as well
so we would prefer the left set up to
test it some people do the people prefer
the right one as well we've got some are
your product managers that's good now
something I like about the right one
it's because of Kafka well you've got a
little different layers it's also nice
to test your client with actual real
data because graph QL servers the thing
with them that you don't really need
versioning because types can change all
the time and could be interesting to
really have those Entenmann's test
implies as well so if you want to learn
more you can also find me on social
media and ask your questions there or
you can just find me on youtube I've got
a lot of videos online and from other
conferences and also from NDC in London
if you want to know more well so those
are things I really explain the
difference between using graph QL and
rest and most of the times I write these
things in
JavaScript's i also use reason monogamy
lots of questions about those things you
can ask me later if you really want to
get started with testing in graphic well
easily with JavaScript then would really
advise you to go to a polo because
they've got a lot of documentation both
for running integration tests also for
sir for mocking for testing resolvers
basically everything is in there and if
you've got more experience with testing
you can also check out the easy graph QL
tester and then never ever look at them
because you can also mock your schemas
you can walk resolvers you can test
resolve versus make test assertions
so basically everything is in there and
also you've got the love tester which is
important to dimension yeah so thank you
for your time and if you have any
questions please let me know